other people didn't take me that
seriously and um
i went to shameless i went to every
party in l.a i promoted myself
shamelessly
i'm mad all the time i can tell you just
you know angry angry angry pain in the
neck
that's why i use humor a lot because it
deflates myself i don't want to
take it seriously because i really do
you know people always say well
interested in the antagonist in my
movies well the point is that they're
also human these are also parts of
the negative parts of who they are make
your own industry
recreate movies don't pay attention to
industry
do your own thing
goodfellas was very special i was
looking for something that
i could find another way of dealing with
genre and i think really that's what
started to get me really interested in
the characters in the world that it
depicted
in a genre that i've kind of felt most
comfortable with over the years
there's something about the underworld
has more to do with the kind of
a working class or a lower working class
existence
from where i come from and so it's
natural for me
that world is something that deals with
very basic conflicts
basic dilemmas moral dilemmas
that i grew up with and so i feel
comfortable with it there's something
about
de niro who understands the humanity of
all kinds of people and could really
uh express that we had some similar
interests
he knew where i came from i knew where
he came from he understood the area
i grew up in and i just think that they
reflect those dilemmas those conflicts
it's kind of comfortable at times to to
do stuff that you feel you
intrinsically know
what i mean is no at least in terms of
body language
dialogue no dialogue
to you that's and did you want to be
famous did you want to be
oh yeah yeah absolutely yes and did all
that generation of people that you met
then yes spielberg and trader and we all
did i mean um
when i was at nyu i know i was a
director i was making a living editing
somewhat
other people's films and and
documentaries and things like that i was
making a living also doing a little bit
of writing but basically
the only thing i really can't do is i
mean really can't do on my own i tried
i have no knowledge of any kind of
lighting or camera work how a camera
works i've tried that
i've done 16 millimeter and things like
that but i'm not where i came from it
was always dark
so do you leave it all almost to your
deal dark and lower yeah well pretty
much
no i designed with him i designed the
shots i designed the movement of the
shots and the size of the frame
i have a real problem sometimes dealing
with the light i don't know where the
light sometimes coming from my eye
for me like it's new york look at us
right now but no no i felt i was a
director and i
i knew i was but other people didn't
take me that seriously
and i went to shameless i went to every
party in l.a i
promoted myself shamelessly we were
writing there's that scene where bob de
niro
is standing at the bar with a cigarette
and he's looking
at manny and he's going to kill him and
you know he's going to kill him
and marty has this shot and he gets
closer and closer and closer and bob's
eyes get more wolf-like it was just the
most
terrifying picture and as i'm typing
that stuff
because i'm the typist he says put in
cream put in cream
i said what cream says just write that
write down cream i said what's what
cream who are you talking about just put
it just put it put
it do me a favor just put it so i've
typed in cream well it turns out
while we're typing that scene he's
already listening to the music
he has a deep sense of how music should
go with the film and by that i don't
mean that that that it should go easily
sometimes it's a shocking choice but it
works like crazy
i kind of see everything with music
especially the juxtaposition of the type
of music you're listening to
to the images that you see out the
window and that sort of thing and i said
that's the way music should be in a
movie what is it about this thing of
filmmaking that turned you on the most
what is it about this process um that
you know is it the editing is it
[Music]
creating the scene for me for me if
first of all you need you need the story
you need the script to be there you need
the script to be there you need it to be
on the page in terms of the emotion
and in terms of uh something with which
the audience can empathize
in terms of characters you need the
audience to care about somebody okay
that's one thing
so we've been taking over the years
we've been pushing we're pushing the
envelope on that though over the years
with mean streets
taxi driver raging bull and particularly
raging bull and even uh goodfellas and
uh casinos so you're pushing the edge
there how much can you care for a person
if he's this bad or she's that bad you
know
can you still care there's some out
there i know can still care so that's
pretty good okay
now let's see if we can push a little
more i have to like the people in the
film i have to love them
the characters are the actors both
actually
yeah both first i start with the
characters
and um if you have actors who are who
are our soul mates too that's great
we also have the same philosophy too uh
de niro has a certain philosophy kaitel
and it's the same place that you have
it's a shared philosophy yeah it is
which is
well dealing with the subject matter
that we see it a certain way
and there's a certain truth that we try
to get to
uh joe pesci too has that about the
about a raging bull or about
about a good fellas or a casino uh that
we just sense when something isn't quite
right
we know that that gesture is wrong you
know you can't
direct it they have to they have to be
it people who are flawed
people like ourselves uh
and to see if anybody else cares about
them there was no tradition of reading
in the house no books um of course i
read in school etc
books in school and that sort of thing
but it was more of a visual tradition
more
uh if i was taken to movie theaters a
lot
also being a sickly child with
a very severe asthma i couldn't play
sports so again the movie theater the
movie theater in the church the church
in the movie theater
and so along with the films uh there was
also the advent of television 1948-49
and the heyday of
really the best some of the best
programming in american television in
the history of
uh american television up to this point
with the 50s 1950s
and so i saw a lot of television shows
but also
films on television uh being working
class family too
they didn't have enough money to go to
theater so theater wasn't an option
um live stage shows so it was mainly
mainly
visual literacy what was what was
happening at
at that time to me i did not understand
that that was happening
what it made me realize was that there
was an intelligence another kind of
intelligence
that was trying to tell a story through
where
the director the writer and the
cinematographer where they were focusing
your eyes
you know whether it was the camera may
be in an extremely low angle
looking up at you
the use of the lens the size of the lens
i began to understand certain lenses
did interpreted the story differently
a longer lens crushed everything
together and made it flat
a wider lens stretched everything and
some don't distort it especially if
camera movement
i learned looking at certain pictures
particularly wells films and and william
weiler
too a wide angle lens the while i used
his wide-angle lens in a very
strong steady image but wells used that
wide-angle lens 18 millimeter it turns
out
um very often to move along the walls
move along
and you really felt i felt as if the
camera was flying as if the story was
flying by
you know um i didn't know why until i
kept seeing the films again and again
as i began to know a little more about
what filmmaking was like and what
cameras did and
that's i still didn't know who made the
pictures you know
but i was beginning to understand that
there are certain certain tools you use
and those tools
become part of a vocabulary that's just
as valid
as that vocabulary that is used in
literature in our language
i love to watch my son direct
i just love to sit there and watch him
direct the picture what about that
what do you like what are you liking
like in like in a regime
regional is one of the greatest tell me
what i don't like i don't like when he
puts me in a picture and then he takes
me out
well that's not fair she went so hard
she was cut out of taxi driver she was
travis's first
passenger that's right with shopping
bags you know
shopping bags again they couldn't get in
the car and getting they were so heavy i
said what do you got mom
you have to go that's it then you think
you took me out i took you out what else
did i take you out
no raging bully took me out of two yeah
well you were only an extra day yeah
you did a big scene in king of comedy
you did the whole conversation with that
girl
all the whole scene in kingdom comedy
with the de niro down in the basement
and his mother arguing with them is all
improvised between the two very good
i thought of that all myself all by
myself
and i tell you he gave me two words and
he says continue
yeah right she wrote wrote down her own
dialogue yeah
and i says to myself i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be smarter than him
okay what about the early days like when
marty was doing murray
when he was wait a minute when he when
he started when he started with these
films
and he used to tell me you have to get
in the picture
i i used to tell him but i'm not an
actress he seems to say to me but you
don't have to be an actress
i said but i don't know how to act he
says mother you either get in the
picture or you pay
money i didn't have so i had to get in
the picture
pay for what for the actress for the
actors
we had no money so i had to get in the
picture tell me how to use me how much
you got for your pot
main streets they gave me twenty eight
dollars and i couldn't say nothing
twenty eight dollars i made suits i had
a big fight with you on the set remember
yeah yeah main streets big fight the
mean streets the part at the end
when the lady when the they're in the
hallway and bobby de niro's
having the fight with with harvey and
she gets a fit
i was so tired i have to i had when i
used to go to work at the time
and it was 1 30 in the morning and he
was sleeping he didn't want to come
he was sleeping and i said to marty
marty please it's late
everybody wants to go home he says we're
going to do this a few more times
well he did it a few times but then i
had i went over to him and i said
marty i have to go to work in the
morning he says to me go in that corner
and don't come out till i call you
that's him she said don't you dare talk
to me that way he said don't try i said
don't you talk to me like that i'm your
mother
he's go in the corner but the problem
was that the people in the building you
see mean streets was mainly shot in los
angeles
but actually actually you told me you
got from so many angles she said you got
it from a wide angle you got a medium
shot
let's go home let's go home that's right
i have to watch it
now we do it this way now we do it that
way so i figured he's going from all
angles
i started to understand the angles so
because you know you know from you know
from the
student films that were able to call us
you know but i couldn't imagine the
beginning what he was doing
you know people always say well
interested in the antagonist in my
movies well the point is that they're
also human these are also
parts of the negative parts of who they
are
evil streak so to speak if you want to
use that phrase
there's also maybe something in us and
something not to be afraid of but to
explore
a lot of his films and especially with
goodfellas
definitely deal in the underworld and
that's been a recurring theme in a lot
of
his work and i think people are
attracted to that but
more so the fact that he's always
trying to grasp the humanity of these
people the flawed nature of these
characters
i think they just reflect aspects of who
we are as human beings
and some things we can't deny or pretend
they don't exist
that's the idea that's very dangerous
because when it
if you're teaching younger people when
they suddenly shock to find out it does
exist no it exists
you know i just want to get you prepared
i don't know how it's going to come at
you but it's going to be there
because that's part of who we are i'm
wondering when you're trying to make a
film and you come up against obstacles
and barriers
what do you attribute your strong
dedication
to getting that film made um
really i
hysteria usually hysteria and obsession
and anger i think mainly anger
i'm mad all the time i might tell you
just you know
angry angry angry pain in the neck
that's why i use humor a lot because it
deflates myself
i don't want to take it seriously
because i really do
i you i would have been gone much longer
25 years ago i wouldn't have survived
but the anger is enormous
about everything about everything and so
that also fueled me to make a picture i
think but keeping the sense of humor is
the key thing the irony
the irony when you get there in the
morning and you get a note
that one actor has had a during this
breakdown and he can't go on with the
film
it happened it happened yeah they don't
want to come out of the trailer
go ahead right here in the black sweater
what are you gonna do you get a heart
attack otherwise
or you killed someone you know it's not
good
that's true yes make your own industry
recreate movies pay attention to
industry
do your own thing i mean
put it this way um you want the work to
be seen
but it doesn't have to be the odeon you
know
no more that's all different that's all
god's another ancient world
that type of film or not even that type
of film the
the the communal experience is always
important you can make a film on a
camera the size of that doorknob and
still show it to
600 people in an audience it's still a
great communal experience
you know it doesn't necessarily mean it
has to cost
over 100 million pounds you know it's
all new you just break it open
break open the form don't just uh just
you know have your tripod and a camera
that's standing on it
the cameras that are being made now and
of course the fact that all
area flex and other cameras have stopped
being made
and whether we like it or not we have to
deal with a new new
technology high definition or
digital whatever it's called it's it
changes cinematography the artichoke
cinematography but
but younger ones
you make a new art take what's available
push it you know because it's going to
go there you could do anything
these are the questions that you have to
deal with if you're making a film to
anyone
who decides what you're leaving the
frame and what you leave out
and that that's the fundamental issue
where do you put the camera which take
do you use
where do you where do you cut or not cut
that's the basic question
now we come full circle to the irishman
you know working with the actors trying
to capture again
kind of a beauty of movement gesture
speech
a lot of the stuff i recall from my own
life growing up um
and that i could really explore further
with you know
incredible artists like pacino and de
niro albertson and i worked was the
first time we were together
on this picture and bob and i returned
to working together again after i think
the last picture we worked on together
was a
casino 1995. so this took a long time
to find the right project and to uh
find the right space so to speak in
which we could operate
and also try to learn more about
ourselves i guess
i'm not sure i may be about making a
movie
you know and we're looking even more
closely
from this vantage point in our lives at
the age of 75 76
we're looking at friendship betrayal
power
trust self-preservation and then maybe
a possibility of a redemption i think
i know at least in my case we all return
to what obsesses us what haunts us
to the questions that deepen and
really become more mysterious as time
goes by as we ask them
you